Damon are you ready I'm just I'm blinded
by the jewelry I am dude it's Christmas
I'm so festive right now you are and I'm
trying I'm gonna make sure not to piss
you off because I can't get punched in
the face with this why would I want to
scratch my jewelry by engaging in
violence with you oh wow that's where
we're gonna start this thing have a
fight between co-stars look out I just
picked this up last week at a charity
auction for the Audubon Society what do
you think it's bad uh mmm what I mean is
it's really bad like it should be named
why cocktails should be banned at
charity auctions this movie is like it's
a little jingle all the way
okay it's a little liar liar oh you work
in politics and then it's a little love
actually wrong combines oh you just
nailed it yeah but if you had to sum it
up with just three words what would
those words be best movie Wow that's
what words but yes Wow Wow that's movie
ever and well I mean I can't top that no
you can that's three words can't can't
top that there we go that should be
close to them yeah can't talk you can't
top that
are you gonna empty hammer it out of
here ah I can't wait to introduce you to
my family before the campaign starts I
need something special for you the
toxics dude that's what they called it
when they warned me about it on the
telephone is the pressure on because you
guys are the first of the original
movies to hit the air yes because with
best there ya can't top that right no
you can't good Wow Wow Wow hey what I
love about this movie is that it's one
of those times where you have an
instinct about something you read it
it's funny it's great I love the
director Jake Harris he specializes in
comedy so reading this and knowing
what's gonna work with him I thought
this is gonna be really good this gonna
be really good and it actually turned
out as great as I hoped there's a
stand-up comedy scene Oh God
was that scripted or is that like
do you bring that act to the table
that's a very yeah is a very good
question so originally there was a
moment in the script where my character
has some hidden talent the network kind
of decided you have any any weird
talents and I thought well maybe have
some weird talents but afford one what I
want to actually do you know I'm camera
or people watch see yeah I know like
what would be interesting to watch ensue
with Jays background you know in
directing comedies and a lot of stand-up
stuff and with my background in comedy
and having done stand-up before I shared
with him a story of how I tried to do
stand-up and enjoyed it and then one day
I just thought I didn't want to do it
anymore and he said you know why why did
you feel like that I said I don't know
just one day I went to a comedy club and
I was gonna go up and do a set and I
just decided I didn't want it he's like
that's it because that's what your
character is going through in the movie
so you get to really see that in that
one scene with that character it's it's
the truth of her creativity and maybe
how she feels about being able to
communicate honestly both on stage and
with her boyfriends family
we took a way deeper than I thought it
would but I loved it she likes to do
this yeah I like a second oh my god this
kind of comedy that I don't like because
it's like you know it just says this
free form it's family-friendly you know
I I was totally family I don't know
where you guys took it yeah like
starting that's all that's on YouTube
and in the spirit of the film can we
play a little game of two truths and a
lie
call the audition I want you guys to say
two things you do at the holidays and
one thing it's a made-up lie right now
and then you have to guess each other's
cuz you guys know each other I don't
know you I just met you okay so each of
us - true yes so two trips in one lie
about your holidays okay
I eat macaroni and cheese I go
rollerskating and I love going to the
movies movies and rollerskating of
truths macaroni and cheese is a lie does
a trick question
there's Larry Hansel I was a trick what
about rollerskating says I don't know I
just I feel like you would be do some
you know everything else pretty dreamy I
love how do you wear I've gotta call you
a jerk I know two truths and a lie okay
I eat scones
I wear pajamas for three days and I play
football outside my family likes to play
football I always want to play football
nobody wants to play I do wear pajamas
for three days that came from an
emotional place for someone yeah please
somebody come play football I just
we got really deep in here you guys know
but I eat a lot of scones you do that I
just did it because I didn't see neat
one no well it was summertime when we
shot it binges at the holidays we still
are you like in your trailer between
tastes like dumping scones in your mouth
like a hidden scone if it's Christmas
fine now
that's so weird you like a hidden stone
finish and I don't know how I feel about
you know well I mean we have to finish
it yeah but you have to share the spoons
you can't just eat them by let's hang
out at Christmas time and all share a
half a skillet or something okay all
right but really live Christmas brought
out a lot of truths today guys
it really did